considera las funciones efe junto con
las gráficas que se muestran a
continuación sijé mayúscula de x es
igual al cubo de g minúscula compuesta
con fx cuál es el valor de la derivada
de g que es que prima evaluada en 5 muy
bien entonces aquí nos dan estas dos
gráficas la azules
efe y la digamos roja o rosa que es más
rosa que roja es que de x muy bien
entonces vamos a ver cómo cómo resolver
este problema o más bien te invito a que
hagas una pausa y que pienses cómo
hacerlo y después comparamos nuestras
soluciones así que quede x lo podemos en
realidad ver o bueno déjame reescribirlo
esto es igual al cubo al cubo vamos a
elevar al cubo lo que está aquí adentro
que es
la función g de x no bueno más bien es g
evaluada no en x sino en fx que vamos a
llamarle fx y la variable vamos a
ponerla con blanco muy bien entonces
ahora podríamos ver esta función
simplemente como una triple composición
si yo defino hdx igual a x al cubo
entonces en realidad estamos componiendo
h con g seguida de fx muy bien porque
estamos elevando al cubo y en vez de
poner x ponemos gdf x muy bien entonces
lo que podemos hacer es que es escribir
esto como gdx igual a h h seguida de
todo esto que está aquí adentro vamos a
vamos a tratar de copiarlo
para no estar cambiando tanto de color
copiar y pegamos
muy bien entonces es esta composición
correcto entonces si nosotros queremos
digamos calcular la derivada de g
entonces ponemos la derivada de g
ok si vamos a ponerlo así respecto de
nuestra variable x en realidad vamos a
usar esta anotación que a lo mejor es un
poco complicada y no es tan convencional
pero es la verdad la verdad es muy útil
y ahorita va a saber por qué entonces va
a ser la derivada copiamos esto es
exactamente lo mismo
y pegamos entonces es la derivada de
esto con respecto d
lo que tenemos aquí adentro con respecto
de gdf x muy bien
con respecto de gdf x
a copiar nuevamente y pegar
ahí lo tienen y luego tenemos que hacer
la multiplicación con la derivada
justamente de lo mismo verdad de gdf de
x parece ser que ya ahí tenemos la línea
amarilla
bueno aquí quizás no debía ir esta línea
solo para que no se confundan y esta es
la derivada con respecto de y ahora
copiamos fx es fx ya lo voy a poner así
y finalmente multiplicamos por la
derivada de fx muy bien de f
de equis y esto lo derivamos con
respecto de x muy bien
ok entonces esta es la idea de la regla
de la cadena simplemente vamos derivando
con respecto a lo que está adentro y
vamos sacando más derivadas
multiplicándose verdad entonces esta es
la derivada con respecto de x y me gusta
mucho esta anotación aunque quizás no es
la más tradicional porque si lo
hubiéramos como infracciones esto en
realidad como como que se cancela en
verdad éste se cancela con este este se
cancela con este otro y al final al
final nos queda la derivada de h de gdf
de x respecto de x que era justo la
derivada de nuestra gema yus q la muy
bien entonces esto sí lo escribimos
digamos con algo un poquito más
convencional nos dice la derivada de g
evaluada en x sería la derivada de h
sería la derivada de h evaluada
en
vamos a seleccionar es justo gdf de x
muy bien
veamos si pegamos
sería evaluar la derivada allí
y aquí está y luego multiplicamos por la
derivada de esa misma cosa bueno esa
misma cosa es que seguida de fx vamos a
pegarlo y simplemente le ponemos aquí su
comilla de
y que estamos derivando
entonces aquí es la derivada de g
evaluada en fx y luego multiplicamos por
la derivada de fx
muy bien qué es ese prima de x perfecto
ahora nosotros en realidad queremos
calcular la derivada de g en 5 muy bien
entonces seleccionamos esto mismo y
vamos a ver qué pasa en el punto
particular que nos interesa copiamos y
pegamos y en lugar de ponerle x voy a
ponerle en siempre que yo vea la equis
le voy a poner un 5 muy bien entonces
estamos esto
más o menos de ahí está limpio de las
equis y ahora ponemos un 5 muy bien
entonces ya ya tenemos todo lo necesario
para hacer estas estas cuentas ahora
vamos a ver qué es lo que ocurre el
primero fíjense muy bien que necesitamos
saber cuál es la derivada en 5 y cuánto
vale la función efe en cinco para
después poder evaluarla en la derivada
de g muy bien y así consecutivamente
entonces si nos damos cuenta la deriva o
más bien la función f evaluada en 5 y
aquí la tenemos
efe evaluada en 5 es menos 1 así que
esto vale menos 1 y es la derivada de g
evaluada en menos 1 verdad entonces esto
en realidad sería algo así como menos 1
todo esto sería menos 1 pero fíjense muy
bien quién es la derivada de f en 5 aquí
tenemos
en 5 aquí está el punto y si nos damos
cuenta es una recta horizontal y éstas
tienen derivada igual a 0 entonces este
término es 0 y entonces tú podrías
seguir calculando la derivada de g en
menos uno y después evaluar que cuando
evaluada ene efe de 5 y calcular la
derivada de h en ese punto y así
sucesivamente pero fíjate que no es
necesario ni siquiera porque aquí
tenemos un un un factor de este producto
que vale cero así que 0 por lo que sea
que esto valga es igual a cero todo esto
va a ser igual a cero ok entonces
también puedes pensarlo de la siguiente
forma piensa que la fx en 5 aquí no
cambia verdad se mantiene el constante
en al menos un intervalo de longitud 2
verdad centrado en en el 5 en realidad
la f no está cambiando en 5 entonces si
f no cambia en 5 pues la que tampoco va
a cambiar alrededor del 5 y si elevamos
al cubo que es componer con extra h
tampoco va a cambiar
y esa es otra forma en que puedes ver y
al menos intuitivamente también entender
por qué nos dio cero